hello I'm playing the role I was
destined to play it I play Alan Thicke
you're guilty as charged
TV's favorite dad's to the small screen
for the last time for why TV's the
Stanley dynamic and only we were invited
on set for one of his final interviews I
told him turn that plane around I'm back
so you're the lead yeah in the story I'm
a little too loud for the rest of them
oh really like hell out just really loud
like loud enough but if I did it right
now every time I did tell us to shut up
in the next studio you want to sing and
we know you love to thing do you and
still do that once in a while I do you
know I I don't call myself a singer
around robbing any more than I'm a
hockey player you taught him you taught
him everything he knows
Gretzky you know but no you need such a
wonderful artist I'm so proud of him and
but I have always enjoyed a little music
writing a little singing way back my
college days when I was in some really
lousy banner where you play guitar and
sing yeah so good to see you Alan thank
you